الى لبنان الان وبعد اكثر من عام تتحرك
التحقيقات الراكده في ملف انفجار مرفا
بيروت خطوه لافته اقدم عليها المحقق
العدلي بعد 13 شهرا من قرار محكمه
الاستئناف وقفه عن متابعه التحقيق المحقق
العدلي يعتمد على اجتهاد قضائيا لاستئنا
في عمله وقرر توجيهه الاتهام لثمانيه
اشخاص بينهم مسؤولين امنيان رفيع المستوى
لضمان النزاهه التحقيقات وحسن سير العداله
يعلن وزير العدل لاحاله قرار المحقق العدل
الى مجلس القضاء الاعلى
معناها الان من بيروت المحاميه سيسيليا
روكس عضو لجنه اهالي ضحايا مرفا بيروت
معنا كذلك من بيروت يوسف دياب الكاتب
الصحافي المتخصص في الشؤون القضائيه وابدا
معك سيد يوسف دياب يعني هناك لبس اجرائي
وقضائي في ما اعلنه المدعي العام من جهه
وامكانيات او امكانيه تنفيذ ذلك فعليا
ما هو الوضع الان
قرار القاضي بيطار اليوم اربك السلطه
القضائيه من اعلى الهرم الى اسفلها قرار
العوده الى التحقيق جاء مفاجئا وغير متوقع
لم يكن احد ليتوقع اليوم ان القاضي
همم يبرز دراسه قانونيه اعدها او عكف على
اعدادها منذ اشهر واليوم قدمها للراي
العام اللبناني يقول انها المرتكز
القانوني التي تتيح له استئناف التحقيقات
المجمده منذ 13 شهرا لا شك اليوم ان ااه
بطار كسر الجليد او كسر الحلقه المقفله في
ملف انفجار مرفا بيروت
وفتح القضيه على الكثير من التكهنات
والكثير من القراءات واضح اليوم ان قرارا
من هذا النوع يعتبره كثير انه قرار افرمت
من المحقق العدلي لا يتيح له استئناف عمله
خصوصا وان الجهه القضائيه التي تسانده
بحسب القانون او التي يفترض ان تسانده
بحسب القانون في اجراءاته وهي النيابه
العامه التمييزيه ترفض او اعطت اشارات
اولى على انها لن تتعامل مع قرارات القاضي
بيطار خصوصا لجهه تصديره همم لائحه
ادعاءات جديده شملت شخصيات سياسيه وقضاه
وامليين عدا عن القرار الذي سيكون محرج
للغايه بالنسبه للنيابه العامه التمييزيه
وهو الافراج عن عدد من الموقوفين في ملف
انفجار مرفق بيروت والذي ستكون النيابه
العامه امام واقع صعب عليها انت عملت
لكن اتحول اليك ده سيسيليا اسيد يوسف يقول
بان هذا القرار يفتح على الكثير من
التكهنات والقراءات انتم من طرفكم ما الذي
يمكن ان يغيره هذا القرار همم لكم بالنسبه
لكم في مسار هذه القضيه ام انه او يعني
محطه جديده في مسار التعقيدات القضائيه
لهذه القضيه
همم مساء الخير اكيد هيدا منه محل منه
قرار ومعقد هو قرار جريء جدا وان احنا
كاهيله ضحايا هذا من اعتبره مثل نسمه همم
بعد كل هالعرقات وكلها التوقيف اللي توقفه
التحقيق احنا اهالي صار لنا سنتين ونصف
على الطرقات والسنه بعد سنه وشهر مجمده
التحقيقات بفعل العرقلات السياسيه
والحزبيه
ما بنقدر نسمي لك اياها 40 دعوه بوجه
القاضي عشوائي راح يطلع هو
هالدعوه كلها بوجهه يعني قرار جريء جدا
ونحنا كاهيله كثير منعوه عليه راح ننتظر
شو راح يكون متراقبين شو بده يكون رديت
الفعل
المحقق صلاحياته واسعه
هذه الجريمه مفترض حاكم كل الاشخاص وكل ما
يكون فيها محاكم استثنائيه لازم كلها تكون
امام المجلس العدلي نحنا مش لازم يكون
لمجلس اعلى ولا محاكم للاوداد خاصه لازم
القاضي هو يحقق مع كل الاشخاص ما يكون في
عنده استثناءات المحقق العدلي عنده صلاحيه
شامله همم قراراته لا تقبل اي طريق من طرق
المراجعه يعني قراره اللي صدر اليوم هو
همم بعثه لنيابه العامه للاطلاع لا يقبل
اي طريق من طرق المراجعه وهو اخلس به بعد
الاشخاص مش معقول يعني هن يحجزولهم
حورياتهم بعد ما القاضي الاصيل همم خلال
سبيلن اساسا كانوا عم بيطالبه اللي هو
خارج عن اطار القانون من اجل البيت لقيت
السبيل القاضي الاصيل اليوم اخلى سبيل خمس
اشخاص مفترض انهن ما يعرف انه هذا القرار
وقال له يعتبروا عم يحجوا حريه الاشخاص يا
اللي اخلي سبيلن طب احنا
اهلك
بنشكر نحن عندنا ثقه بالمحقق العدلي ونحنا
الاخلاءات السبيل اللي تمت اليوم عنها ثقه
بي قراره هو سيد ملفه هو بيخلص سبيل هو
بيعرف عنده معطياته نعم نعم
سيد يوسف يعني وقد قلت بان السلطه
القضائيه لم تتعامل مع قرارات البيطار لما
تمثل من ربما احراج لها ما هي
السيناريوهات المتوقعه من قبل يعني كل
الاطراف ان كان النيابه العامه والاطراف
العام نفسه
لا واضح يعني كما قالت الاستاذ سيسي لان
قرارات المحقق العدلي هي قرارات مبرمه ولا
تقبل الطعن ولا المراجعه همم ما اتخذه
القاضي بيطار اليوم من اجراءات اصبحت في
عهده النيابه العامه التميزيه وهذه
النيابه العامه اليوم باتت امام امتحان
اما تنفيذ قرار القاضي بيطار والتعامل معه
على انه اا يعني قرار قانوني وبات واقعا
ويجب التعامل معه بايجابيه واما ترفضه
وهذا سيرتب عليها تداعيات ايضا ليس فقط
على المستوى القانوني بل على مستوى الشارع
اللبناني الذي كان ينتظر بالدرجه الاولى
استئناف التحقيق المجمد منذ اشهر طويله
وعلى المستوى الثاني اخلاء سبيل الموقوفين
الذين همم دائما ما كانت تتعالى الصرخات
باعتبار ان اكثرهم انضم مده محكوم في ويجب
ان يفرج عنه انا بتقديري القاضي بيطار لن
يتوقف همم فقط عند قبول او رفض النيابه
العامه التمييزيه لقراراته هو همم سيد
قراره اذا نفذت قراراته وجرى تبليغ المدعي
عليهم ضروره المثول امامه كان به وعندها
تسير الامور من دون مزيد من النزاعات
القانونيه اذا رفضت ذلك سيكون له خيارات
اخرى منها اصدار مذكرات توقيف بحق من
يمتنع عن المثل امامه للاسف لن استطيع
العوده
شكرا لكما من بيروت يوسف دياب بالكاتب
صحفي متخصص في الشؤون القضائيه
وكذلك اشكرك اسيليا رقص
بيروت كنت معنا ايضا من بيروت